let's accept this one and let's accept
he lowering the player will accept
inferno the longest person to wait okay
this will be interesting
so this game will clearly have odds
because I have to focus on this game
first
so good luck this is going to be raw
material and winning material
this is just complete chaos this
actually my time situation is not like
so bad these games my al fun time in
both I'm almost off on time in this game
okay triple battery going for meat let's
take this play this move tricky move
yeah the YouTube video will be bullet
Simoes okay one more game YouTube say hi
back to probably that was tog II okay
it's still alive what did you miss move
take stuff that was Howie
okay to stay focused full domination
there we go okay man that was intense
it's harder on the smaller screen to to
move accurately let's go okay who's next
play this game and this game okay London
time
duh it's easy to master just playing the
same salad on both games but there's
some differences Thank You Alexander's
horse okay going for meats probably play
the same idea in this game let's play G
for once I play 95 94
I'm trying thank you Aries arts and talk
to you again let's play this move
delayed bond cloud one play 9 f3
ooh free Queen so generous so many
people being generous I played Bishop c2
to go for this stuff hey g5 it's got
some g5 g 4 emotes in the chats okay I
can take this I will just taking mix
screens like castle oh what a Fantasia
what does that mean maybe I don't know
what don't want to know what it means
but okay I'll treat that as a good thing
um what does this move also let's start
a new game have to move quick though
let's play The Walrus what is this for
Bishop is trapped man another Brook
ending time scramble in d5 7th heaven
let's take a pawn let's take this place
move beats okay
good game we'll start a new one sure
we'll play a tune I came
okay a two-minute bullet will be a bit
more manageable tricky
oh that light was hey Nia Oh white has
to play Queen d2 only legal move it's
gonna be made very soon
tough game like d5 soon okay she's gonna
keep starting games gypsy for free pawn
on d5 a 509 t3 a 5 comes I want to trap
the bishop I want to win the reckon rook
e8 some move I guess play this move I
just want to go for a back rank mates or
winning a pawn 5 humming I'll come back
for anything f2
my whites a bit stuck here there's a
Knights pinned FG was gonna fall maybe I
have another potential for monster
Knights now it doesn't quite work cuz
rookie one I'll go back to f5 I want to
do this this this or just want a free
nights okay let's take off to pawn my
goals to have a rook each six meet and
ends
I think Whitehead forced me in like
close to the final position why had made
into with queen takes f7 that was almost
really close queen takes f7 is just meet
next move it takes me and if here the
night wait what why can't I move Oh what
happened
refresh oh that was weird
maybe it's one of the issues of doing a
Simon not used to having two games at
once okay let's play who created 23:02
okay let's just take our night we have
an Italian go for this typical night
maneuver
it's nice when my pawns thinking here
just have to keep an eye on it
tough game
okay oh I'm getting forts opponent
missed it though oh no my queen okay I
have to say focus now um this might be
my first loss and these bullets I'm
wills oh dear I can take and ooh okay
I'm winning back material because Knight
g5 I start another game it start another
game oh I'm not being bad material aha
why did I start another game let's play
this move mm-hmm okay no I have to
finish this game first let's play that
move I'm gonna take here next that's
tricky Jack g5 okay
trying to trap the Queen okay let's play
this move staying clean it's close to
losing that game let's play this person
this move okay it's hard State starting
the games at different times but maybe
in some sense it makes it easier when
they're staggered this move
I'm already low on time here time
management
wanna play each for Bishop almost
wrapped wish me five yeah I know if six
will be next up on time both games play
this move what's going on here just want
to attack can take take with the rook
it's actually kind of looking that would
have been kind of scary this game I have
little time I just want to meet good
game take this way and that way
okay what a fitness man
this is a lot of chess it's a lot of
Poland it's very energy draining I'm
gonna do one more or actually two more
games one more subtle to wrap things up
I'll play the two highest rated players
will play this person and this person
writes yeah two players over two
thousand okay this will be the biggest
challenge just a focus I'm black in both
games good luck Oh Halloween get it man
this is
mmm it's really hard oh wait maybe I'm
reading something takes takes of this
hmm what's going on here this month oh
no I'm losing stuff no oh my gosh let's
play that move let's play this move
okay let's take a queen Jack and meat
okay time to focus on this game I'm down
the queen but I have hope lots of hope
like take the rook whoo
now I have more hope play this move to
do a five oops I let's play rook d3 soon
win a pawn take a bishop okay
that's tough it helped to have a quick
win here to focus on the other game man
okay um I think I'm gonna end it there
oh there's there's a hyper bullet
challenge okay
this will be my final test the final
boss much higher rated players this is
hyperbole this is bullets good luck
people
hmm that's good start
no let's battle dad move
okay that's good no I lost I lost again
uh-uh oh that's so difficult it's so
difficult
okay I think we'll end it with that I
really try were those rated games too
those were both rated games I got
tricked by law firm I lost 12 and then
14 points what's my rating now
[Music]
I fell below 2,700 so said all trying
rebounds next time I didn't realize that
those were rated anyway I hope people
enjoy that you two people watching in
the future
say hi to tog II you can leave an F in
the comments I'll be back